after three months it's the day many
European countries lift border controls
hello everyone I'm Philippa gal from the
French border town of Chinook for France
24 and I'm Melinda crane for DW standing
on a German sidewalk alongside the
French main street we're in the saw
region where European Economic
Cooperation began 70 years ago last
month we're gonna be asking whether
those border controls left a bitter
taste as we embark on a new phase can
the franco-german motor drive EU
recovery our title grand reopening
France 24 + DW join up at the border for
the debate welcome and 388 kilometers
away is Ludovic subhan the French
capital Paris chief economist at
insurers and asset managers Allianz
thanks for being with us and we're
joined by kinder Hoffman he is president
of Germany's powerful trade union
confederation the D G B and let me start
out with a question to you by no huffman
when Corona hit you urgently appealed to
EU member countries to coordinate their
responses to the virus that didn't
happen
here at this border as it reopens would
you say that Germany's unilateral move
to reimpose border controls was a
mistake yes it was a mistake because we
meet experiences all Member States are
affected by the corona and me and more
coordinated response from the early
beginning would have been much better
than every Member States went on his own
way and Germany didn't gave the best
example at the early beginning mr. Paul
you have roots in this part of France
your thoughts um my mother is actually
from there and and I worked from the
largest insurer who happens to be German
so for me closing the french-german
border was a heartbreaker and I agree
that you know it was stupid and it is
because Trust was very low that every
country in the European Union decided to
manage the crisis on its own and now we
are asking
an act of faith and reopening as if
nothing happened but most of the
countries and especially most of the
companies will remember this as a scar
but quite some time quite some time you
say and that's the big question here
locally we spoke to the recently
re-elected mayor of sure neck Gabrielle
Bastian it was a Friday night suddenly
here we are on the French side over the
other side of the street it's the German
side and these barriers come up saw
something on your couch as well is what
togheter almanzo's only did he anybody
hmm the bhattacarya belacan significant
struggled a lot on the pub a
professional man resolved on approval
people snowfalls poppies wang-jae tip
revenue police a bit on he could feel
the massage
agitate on a personal memory a looter it
a perfect 180 palcohol copies on filming
took place font yeah yeah cool and you
have essential care workers who work at
the hospital in sub weakened customer
Lupita Donny's you seemed on his own
police don't allege to haul in the wall
a potential sonic seesaws al monkey
Kira's eg new will this leave scars
polymer molecular process from Vic see
it so vixx's buku doha mark near a
pistol if la república de 472 firm a
Peruvian more federal a Peruvian modulus
ah just percussive arrested a second
petrolatum economy goddamn it he thought
oh no no no communist a very local
district was a visa Mussolini Campos
their weekly merely mayor the
they convene the circum lemme Elizabeth
let me revolutionary ideas not retreat
Reza McHale the remember is a combatant
arsenic is Nakamoto al mahalla kappa ooh
bastion does it change for you
personally the way you see Europe which
is really super job crispy decision upon
seppuku sorry ray african-american
culture Mike I'm sorry frontier echoed
you wanna settle laguna de visite a la
francaise a proctored you gonna do Inaba
a lot more than just istic literally
virtual money Charlie's emotionally
commit Willie
the whole place off their phones Camilla
okay problem
Hey look for citizen are you eating a
lot of the townspeople here have not
forgotten that viral video of a 65 year
old Frenchman who was pushed to the
ground by German police when he sneaked
across the border to buy cigarettes we
also have people who told us of cars
being keyed and basically not being
welcome across that border we are taping
the show in front of a local restaurant
that found itself in a no-man's land
when the barricades went up and cut this
town in half German restaurant owner
Thomas itzá says even when he finally
reopened after lockdown
the lack of French customers badly hurt
his business
ah ding - money stood aghast Almeida
from the dolphin was a nun via sin alpha
Ananda angry reasons the world via of
different Souls and we differences on
our phones via Deutsche begin ganna fan
clash iron coffin busan the Lehman's
middle difference those in common here
at swoons in an answer handled I give to
Sophie like a chef to German Amish men
kinda the through pimping zips each
artists put sent from France a shock
when roughly what do you expect from the
European Union going forward
yamir does as a soldier country's own
niche McGee progress in science and we
evolved into salmon grilled avocado
salmon and US soldiers reason Cuyler in
java.lang of leaked 4 inch shaft typed
does is see a shmatte slash
this year flash superstein last man
testa sushi it was Manny Evelyn of
Kubota Tasman a solution a Sri Lankan
later Curtis Mosman all songs in
Emanuele Anika who is a the house file
on awesome food again and Bosma fish
France awesome Bhushan from renze in
bertrand of dim park but spartan own so
i done so far since no the ionic
missions of my clash then does the
school the school deborah here in tunic
that's cool in gas fella it's watered
electron and on diagram can consume to
summon hardened
yeah Belinda you mentioned how the this
restaurant is in a no-man's land I'm
standing on a piece of sidewalk here
that is right in France if I put my foot
here I'm actually in Germany and that
gives you an idea
Reiner Hoffmann your thoughts on whether
this will leave lasting scars yeah I
think the experiences we made over the
last couple of weeks is that you know
was not really in a position to
cooperate much stronger together we make
a lot of painful experiences in border
regions and don't forget all the people
coming from France working in Germany
all the utterly a lot going to to France
this has been really difficult difficult
period of time when intentions have been
created which have been it's my opinion
entirely unnecessary if a much more
coordinated cooperation would have
happened Louise you do ichiba is this a
systemic problem with the European Union
or was this just well the panic because
we we'd never seen a pandemic like this
one before of course there is an element
of panic I think it was a first for many
of us it's a it's once in a generation
and hopefully only once but but I think
the the resentment also started very
strongly when it was about the sanitary
scandal that we went through in France
people were extremely disappointed to
hear that our German neighbors had tests
and masks and we didn't have any so I
think that there is of course the the
original sin which is how weak the
European Commission has been at the
beginning at the onset of this crisis
but very quickly we saw also the
divergence when he came to the number of
infected people on the number of
casualty which created this sense of
nervousness and there were mistakes
remember that there was export of mass
from Germany to Italy that was you know
a bone of contention at one point and
people remember this and and also the
way we we behaved I would say at the
onset of the crisis between government
was not
perfect so so I hope that we will
overcome this resentment and that now we
are gonna build something strong
together Germany's gonna be it's gonna
hold the presidency of the European
Union on the 1st of July and it's a very
defining moment for European solidarity
and sovereignty which are the first time
we hear those words even in the world of
of the German Foreign Office let us come
back in a few minutes to the question of
that German EU council presidency but
first a question to both of you briefly
about potential political implications
from the resentments that you have both
described and that we heard about in
those interviews with people here in the
town ludovick subha you have worked for
the French finance ministry you know
French politics very well do you see the
potential for the economic pain and
frustration that were voiced they're
sparking perhaps right-wing nationalism
in regions like this one I mean
historically this region has been one of
the bastion of my independence in spite
of the very European sentiment you just
described so so I think what is sure is
that everybody is concerned about these
health and economic crisis morphing into
a political and a social crisis
especially in France because of the
severity of the recession the severity
of the confinement and also some of the
policy mistakes that are in the making
when it comes to not restarting the
engine soon enough so if everybody is
kind of worried and and everybody's
looking also what's happening in Germany
because indeed the Chancellor Merkel has
a record high level of popularity while
president macro is actually losing steam
so we also looking a little bit how the
other countries are going to vote on on
the on the aftermath of this year and
writer Hoffman just briefly your
thoughts on potential political
implications of these wounds that you
talked about a moment ago
yeah I think the risk is high as you
have described in France if he could get
it could gain political capital out of
this crisis but on the other hand if
things are going better and if the
pandemic is under control and if
economic recovery starts soon I think we
have also a huge number of opportunities
if especially from France and Germany
going in the same direction and there
are some reasons to be optimistic writer
Hoffman we spoke with a man who works in
a factory that makes auto brakes parts
and you can imagine he was not pleased
to hear that Pujol was thinking of
bringing posted workers 50 of them from
Poland to work at their factory over in
mess while there are these partial
layoffs again does the European Union
need to review its rules yeah especially
when it comes to post workers we saw
that this is to some extent reason that
explore exploited and we need much
better safety rules for postal workers
and the directive which has been
reformed by the European Union could be
a positive basis to do much better it's
something that many Michel talked about
on the campaign trail that was in 2017
it's years ago implementing this
European directive into national law and
I hope in the next years I'd like to
come back to that question of
franco-german the cooperation that RINO
Hoffmann mentioned a moment ago it was
born nearly 70 years ago here in
Europe's coal belt when producers of
coal and steel in France and Germany
pooled their resources under joint
management as we heard earlier from a
local history buff whose blog depicts
that time here in this town the European
Coal and Steel community brought
stability to a region that the
two countries had fought over for
centuries as a masseur speeding and
resisting our East Side wah
in this anoxic site into Japanese fear
Alice when this is a coal industry or 30
seconds
Scheckter Hibernia teasing guns and
freaking out about anger burden the
sauce here which dish does this industry
and silt read a VHF dish of an top level
so common than VAT is equal to a via
varney Abijah tuition funded is equal to
a gap raked when this is obviously a
fish dish women die by - parents priests
mahatmas malarkey by the interest god
when devices yeah - women it's yet
simpler than in freedom label when does
this kind click my gift the secessionist
e dition stir open these are home page
of mine just let me ask Ludovic super
can the rusty German French motor be
retooled Mechelen macaw appear to have
gotten it up and running again but is
that a temporary recovery or do you
think that their plan for bringing
growth back to Europe after Co vyd can
actually drive
robust resilience here in this region
well certainly this was what we've been
expecting for the last three years right
every one of them was giving a speech
and the other was sounding a bit busy
and not answering back so this time they
actually agreed to something quite
groundbreaking
this so-called Hamiltonian moment on the
750 billion euro for the European
Commission to be able to finance the
recovery is groundbreaking the next
generation you is groundbreaking but
more importantly I think we are coming
out of crisis much less naive when it
comes to the us-china revelry and our
place as Europe as a sovereign Europe as
a strong Europe in this global
geopolitical nightmare so I think the
French and the German are quite serious
about it and I think it will actually be
the beginning of something then how long
it will take how successful will we be
it will depend on all of us to work
together companies have always been much
more
Europeans and governments so we should
trust the private sector to do that and
not try to be which the French love to
do be to interventionists because that
was really what you know could be for me
the the big I would say disincentive for
for this recovery to be joined and to be
shared and to be successful let me just
remind our audience that the Hamiltonian
moment essentially refers to a
comparison with the history of the
United States when in the 18th century
Alexander Hamilton actually persuaded
the original US states to mutual eyes
their debt in other words to take
responsibility for each other steps and
that is an element of the miracle macro
plan for European recovery it's an
element that President Macau mentioned
yesterday evening in his speech to the
French nation when he expressed
confidence in the plan that he and the
German Chancellor have introduced a
plunderer construction Sephardic la
tierra de beauté amid CEC allotted imamo
laka Franco Elmo o to Dan Odette ma
Kuzma Eden planned arrest is Mapo road
race a lacuna me do continue a tanto
know in stoic
oh no kata o la première fois ensemble
avocation salir del man you know papa
zoom Azad Rosetta's open do you know to
talk in addition dessert together with
your French Union colleagues and Hoffman
you have applauded the macro macro plan
but that optimism that we just heard
there from president makan doesn't
exactly capture the mood of people here
in this region what can you and your
French colleagues in the French Trade
Union Confederation what can you do to
ensure that recovery really reaches
people in regions like this one I think
it will be quite important that what
McCoy and America has agreed will be
accepted or by or other member states
which is a long way to go and it has
been mentioned that Germany will take
over from the first of
the EU presidency and I see that the
German government has a huge
responsibility to get recovery program
on the roads which is ambitious and
which is really targeted that recovery
can take place soon and I quite
convinced that if France and Germany
taking their responsibility that we are
we have an opportunity to use this
crisis as a chance for much closer and a
much more social Europe and as you have
mentioned we have to see this in a
broader context what is going on the
United States what is going on in Asia
in China and what kind of role Europe
will be able to play in the future and
if you don't use this opportunity I
think then we are facing a big failure
and nobody has interested you in that
speech Sunday night Ludovic subha we
heard the French president use words
like sovereignty independence of course
it means different things for different
people as you said earlier this village
where I'm standing sure neck voted for
marine lepen in the second round of the
presidential election they it ahead of
the menu and Max Hall voted for the
far-right economic sovereignty that
means different things for different
people in this Europe we live in you
know as a French working in Germany you
know the French were always seen as
their interventionist you know we wanted
European champions and in England faced
with with Trump and Xi Jingping and and
then the the Germans especially the
business community was always saying no
no no our trend is our lace affair we
are a French word by the way beacon of
hope of capitalism we shouldn't
intervene too much and now Germany
becoming French in a way because you
know the static that amigo burger speaks
himself about sovereignty so I think we
will take yet another you know a few
months to define what we really mean by
sovereignty Germany during the
presidency of the of the European Union
will also talk about European public
goods you
president macron used to talk about by
european act all of that are very strong
words but as you say how do they
translate on the ground how do they
translate in cities like sunic where
people everyday live the French German
friendship and and I think this is gonna
be this for me will be the proof in the
pudding of the next few years and and
for Chancellor Merkel because the
elections are coming in Germany and and
my car has a bit more time but they will
have to leave it in the real the real
life of these people to make sure that
is not just few words and and the French
intellectual concepts that has been
thrown at a crisis that has been very
severe and with you know life-changing
moments for people like those of shinnok
young I don't often what should we be
buying European or what should we be
making in Europe that we're not making
right now I think we are faced with
independently from the corona pandemic
we are facing big challenges driven by
climate change and the European trade
union confirmation together with the
French University GB we are asking for
an ambitious investment programme and
this has to be to be tailored in a way
that really people can make positive
experiences at the ground in all units
abilities it is a change and the common
challenge no Member States will be able
to check a little own and this is
something I think we have to be pretty
clear what season expecting and that the
transition writer Hoffmann what do they
want the EU France and Germany to invest
in specifically yeah for example in
transport systems we need a new concept
of mobility so what does it mean if you
have fast trains coming from Madrid via
Barcelona Paris Cologne
Berlin - ah so this is nothing very very
strategies and this has to be to be made
more precise let me go to you Ludovic
subra to ask about a couple of those
possible cultural differences when it
comes to intentions for the recovery
plan Francois just mentioned sovereignty
can mean different things to different
countries would you expect to see Europe
it may be reopening its borders as we
can see by the way from all the traffic
passing on this street that was very
cried for a long time Europe may be
reopening its own borders but are we
seeing Europe potentially more closed in
future when it comes to global trade you
know the corner virus has been one of
the most severe shock on trade we're
gonna lose close to three trillion
dollars of exchange of goods and
services in 2020 that that's a first
and of course everybody in the recovery
is trying to have this reshoring you
know narrative whereby people are gonna
try to save jobs and protect jobs and
maybe you know compact supply chains a
bit more and this is where I think you
know the German and the French
perspective will be very different
the French have always been much less
dependent on global trade than German
which has been Mark Antony's by nature
so Germany in the conn-young
to pockets the stimulus program is
trying to help local consumption Germany
by investing in the French German Accord
for the recovery is trying to have
outlets in Europe that are stronger in
Italy in Spain in France but German is
model is very dependent on demand from
Asia on demand from the US and so I
don't know to which extent we're gonna
be in sync when it comes to you know how
protection is we want to be or how
retaliatory we want to be towards China
or towards the US or towards the ASEAN
country the Southeast Asian
trees are clearly doing dumping fiscal
and social to be part of the global
chain after coding and so how are we
trying how will we address this when we
have very different stakes we don't have
the same providers we don't have the
same clients how can we have the same
voice that's gonna be really something
you know up for discussion in the next
months let me let me ask Rena Hoffmann
for his reaction to that a lot of the
jobs of the industries that you
represent in the German trade unions
Confederation depend on exports is this
something that concerns you a possible
movement toward a more closed or more
state interventionist Europe some people
say that the government's hand is going
to become much much heavier in the wake
of Corona I think you are right that
especially is depending very much from a
strong export industry forget this and
our first target and first goal should
be and this is what the French trade
unions at the DVB has made clear a
couple of weeks ago that we are
depending so much from Europe and that
European recovery is important for
Germany but it is important for France
and Italy and Spain if people are in not
in good circumstances if they are
suffering in Italy then German workers
will suffer a couple of months later so
we have to act much more together that's
the first thing and the second thing is
if it comes to the global is the ongoing
globalization process here the corona
pandemic I think learned our lesson that
we should use you as a tool for a new
agenda setter for agenda setting there
it is will be much more fair it will be
much more sustainable as it was in the
past and again this cannot be done by a
single member stage cannot be done by
France or Germany alone we can act only
as straw
partners together at the European level
together with the European Union if
we've seen a spike Reiner Hoffman in the
rise of populism this past decade it's
because we already had a continent-wide
emergency in 2007-2008 and there's a
feeling among citizens that the banks
got bailed out but not the people this
time around what will be different will
it just be multinational corporations
that will get bailed out or will it also
be workers that will be out no I think
first of all workers have to experience
that they got the support which which is
needed and secondly we have to make sure
that companies are taking up their
responsibility and that means for the
next couple of weeks that dismissals
should be limited that he should avoid
an increase in unemployment if
unemployment figures are on the increase
I think Europe will be in a very
difficult situation and this could be a
new source for riping parties
anti-european movements if we don't
deliver what workers are expecting
they're expecting security and safe jobs
let me ask both of you this as you have
said and as president macro emphasized
last night German French cooperation is
reviving it's looking stronger than it
has in quite some time on the other hand
Germany is vastly out spending all other
EU member countries when it comes to
national recovery rescue packages
couldn't that unfairly tilt the playing
field going forward in others words
represent a real advantage for this
already disproportionately strong German
economy compared to other countries
Ryno huffman I'll start with you and get
a reaction this is a very serious point
and the risk is very high and here I
think it's absolutely necessary that
also the German government
has to take up their responsibility as
they have agreed in the coalition
agreement on the future of Europe that
Germany has to spend more towards the
European Union that Germany has the
responsibility that we get our own
fiscal capacity that the March annual
financial financial framework will be
handled under the German presidency this
has to become a success if this will be
a failure I think Europe will be at risk
and this is not good for German citizens
Ludovic suebob your reaction to that
perhaps as a Frenchman working in
Germany do you think Germany is ready to
really take European solidarity
seriously in the sense of putting its
money on it yeah I think so but as an
economist I'm always looking at you know
what what's happening underneath and and
the issue is of course that you still
have voices against the European Central
Bank and the low or negative interest
rates because Germany's savers feel that
they're being taxed the issue is that
the business community fears for future
corporate tax increases and so of course
everything that is spent now is seen as
a debt to the future this is still very
much what the German business community
is looking at but but I believe that
Germany is is coming out very strong
from this crisis in the way it is
committing itself to its own - to its
neighbours to its outlets Germany is
taking a form of leadership that is
economic but that is that is also in
terms of policies you know in France we
adopted codes abides the the the Inferno
from Germany because we know it works
in 2008-2009 to safeguard jobs how you
know much more cooperative can we be
than this right but the future is of
course about you know making sure that
you mentioned this the sphere that is
very present in France that France is
lagging behind that the
manufacturing sector will never be
stronger
you know than the you know its neighbors
and that we see Germany putting a lot of
money and in France you know because of
the past money spent we cannot do as
much so that's gonna be of course
something that leaders Federation's like
hair off man's Federation and you know
the the unions will have to discuss and
to reassure one another to show how it
is important how important it is that
supply chains work together instead of
trying to see this cannibalistic Europe
we need to go from rules to trust we
need to go from safety net to
springboard we need to go from you know
a real cooperation that means that yeah
maybe reshoring will mean that will we
have more workers in one country but
another than another but in the end it
will mean more workers in both countries
and this is something that we really
need to start explaining now to avoid
that two years down the road we have
another Greek moment for me that's the
biggest fear I have and I want to avoid
that at all cost by explaining really
what we doing right now and what should
happen but you know leaks you Paul you
mentioned earlier how the private sector
is often more European than the
politicians nonetheless there is that
fear that those corporations are gonna
yes take advantage of this crisis well
to fire a lot of people increase their
productivity as was the case again in
2008-2009 well this is the actual this
is the real second wave right jobs and
bankruptcies on the mind of politicians
that's why for example the the German
government decided to do the stimulus
packet now to avoid you know a massive
you know a period of unemployment and
end bankruptcies in France we've
postponed the decision to September but
but we have this very strong you know
short term placement programs and we're
working on trying to make sure that
bankruptcies don't happen at least big
bankruptcies that happen but this is
this is gonna be of course you know a
very domestic issue to manage if some
governments don't show that they are the
measure up to the needs the social needs
of the countries then the entire
European sentiment will come back but
the the one difference is that
we have on both sides of the Rhine
leaders that actually don't blame it all
on Europe we will not you know make the
mistake of 2012 again we've been
vaccinated against this mistake we
cannot blame it all on Europe we need to
explain the positive in Europe and this
is all what it takes to make sure that
even though we may have social
difficulties in each country it doesn't
jeopardize the the broader need for
stronger Europe a more industry industry
Lee independent Europe a more autonomous
than sovereign Europe and just a
politics question the domestic one Lido
victory ball you mentioned how uncle
Americo announced that rolled out that
huge stimulus package it seems to be
coming piecemeal here in France why
didn't we have a a big bazooka moment
from a menu and back home when it comes
to you know talking about the auto
sector aerospace tourism why didn't he
do it all in one blow
we don't have the same countries right
so the French I mean the French
policymakers right now are convinced
that demand is not the problem that we
should all do supply and productive
investment and we need to boost
potential growth because we were so
profligate before there is a part of
truth in here but it true that in a
sense it means that they are choosing
they're picking the sectors that is very
French to be interventionist on the
contrary in Germany because of the room
to maneuver and because of the need for
quite some time to give these incentives
to consumption and investment because
there wasn't investment gap then you had
this big bazooka with the temporary v80
reduction and so forth
so I think it's the history of two
countries and you cannot expect that
magically we will be in sync on
everything when the crisis hit but of
course we're gonna have to converge in
some ways if we want this recovery to be
as shared as we are like it's expecting
it to be last question to both of you
with the request for a very short answer
if you would because we are just about
out of time
Randa Hoffman mentioned earlier in the
program turning a crisis into an
opportunity essentially a quote from
Churchill saying never waste a good
crisis the fact is the EU has had quite
a few crises in the past eight years and
it hasn't always made good use of them
what do you think how optimistic are you
that things will be different this time
right
I'm quite optimistic and we will make
huge pressure towards the German
government to take up their
responsibilities in the second half of
this year and Ludovic super well I will
do like mr. Hoffman on my side of the
ride just to make sure that we keep them
accountable for what they're probably
seeing the people because we kind of
missed that one absolutely thank you
very much to both of you it's a it's a
it's a glass half-full kind of day
Melinda if you're optimistic you never
say it's always half full let's make it
that way thank you very much to both of
you for being with us here on the debate
as DW joins up with France Beckett all
right many thanks Melinda Crain many
thanks to you for joining us as well bye
for now